well trying to beat the clock for nearly
10 years former unlv and nba player
jackie robinson has tried to get his
all-net resort project off the ground
yeah deadlines for that north end of the
strip property have come and gone really
over that decade the ultimate deadline
though looms this fall in an 8 news now
exclusive john langler sits down with
robinson to talk about a new twist to
the all-net offer
in a town that moves fast jackie
robinson's dream has moved achingly slow
2013. now we're ready to move forward
2017. you only have i feel one
one body of the apple last year now
is the proper time that we failed is for
us to be able to move forward tuesday i
set the goal for october
we are here now perhaps massive 4.2
billion dollar projects always take this
long either way robinson says his
all-net resort and arena is primed for
another groundbreaking for real this
time we're on track we're very happy
where we are right now the all-net site
on the north strip would include a hotel
retail a sports arena but no gaming we
have to do it this this summer that
summer deadline comes from clark county
commissioner tick sega bloom if you
can't do something by september we've
been over backwards i've given you every
opportunity you you need you've always
said it's it's going to be it's right
around the corner so it's kind of now or
never robinson says he has all the
financing he needs but allnet's trying a
new approach to supplement the
traditional investment in this case
we're using crypto yes robinson is
working with quest crypto to connect
cryptocurrency with a tangible asset his
resort robinson compared it to those
junk bonds used to help build the modern
day strip this is the way of the future
but at the same time we have to be
prepared that if we only raise one
dollar in crypto that the project gets
built sicker bloom is trying to be
optimistic the proof will be in the
pudding and when you actually have that
worker out there being handed a paycheck
in dollars then we'll know it's real
unlike before now robinson knows he
can't push deadlines anymore when the
clock strikes fall if shovels aren't in
the ground it's game over
john langler live local now
robinson's target is to break ground in
june possibly july he says he still
hopes to bring an nba team to las vegas